all right so I'm going to give a video
to to explain my answer I gave uh the
question basically is what do you do um
if you're training in a dojo that does
not understand the Tactical necessity
for spinal displacement in Kon waza as
tactical Solutions so you're you're
either told to just hold just stay
stationary and hold okay uh because
again as that is not the Tactical
opening for Kon
waza um as tactical
Solutions um you now have to do things
that obviously don't make sense
martially but again um energetically
which is the main point of kihon waza uh
you you will have a harder time
especially if you
are not yet skilled in the energetic
aspects you will have a harder time
trying to accomplish energetically what
you're trying to accomplish by somebody
who just stands there and grabs you okay
so the question is well I don't want to
do that I'd like to make Marshall sense
and or I'd like to have the energetic
aspects being cultivated in my hea what
do I do okay uh the first solution I
would say is tell them to push like just
say hey can you push a little
but maybe your teacher will go come
around like it depends on where you are
in the social hierarchy your teacher
will come around and go I don't want you
to push I want you to Bear down and and
and crank down like you know if you were
in a iwama do or something like that um
okay the next solution I would go to is
get a friend make a friend and train in
the right way outside of dojo class
structure okay and as you climb in rank
which you will cuz is just hang out long
enough uh as you climb in rank and as
you get Social Power social capital in
there uh and it's your turn to run some
classes you can run classes like that
that would be my next option all right
and then uh if you're like well that's
not going to work or that's going to
take a while um I guess the other option
is move go to another Dojo i' try that
one next uh but okay none of that's
working okay here's what you can do okay
so uh I have to tell my UK what to do CU
we don't do this so let me get him into
ballpark you're just you're just going
to stay still with no pressure there you
go okay I will go back out of range okay
so everyone who does that just like
anyone
else they have a a a precognition of
where they're going to land and do that
grip from from out there do you get it
so if my hand is there he's going to
look at it and his body mind is telling
him that's where I'm going to close my
hand okay so like with all things that
we want to do when we use iy uh the
adhesion cannot it has to remain at
neutral yangong so it's deviations and
whatever Vector that I use it has to be
gradual if you make sharp angles or
reverse angles you're going to go
positive Y and you're going to lose the
adhesion okay um so we're going to use
that concept here I'm not going to call
it I myself um of just
gradual um addressing of what you're
doing okay so as he goes to do that I
got that little
movement
stay there where you are do you feel how
your weight shifted on your on your
front leg now yes you feel that yes okay
so
um as opposed to he comes in I stay here
he's he's grounded he's actually falling
backwards on that foot okay uh but this
would be equally wrong you go like this
the people are going to stop because you
radically change where they wanted to
land okay so that that would be one way
to do it it's just sure there you just I
just did it okay you had a little bit of
forward progress into the movement okay
uh the best way of doing that is to give
them the hand as bait uh like you would
in any number of weapons techniques so
I'm shifted on the front foot do you see
where I am and as he comes in I shift on
that back fo foot and then you already
got enough weight to to do whatever you
wanted to do okay it's not going to be
right but as we already said I think
this is like the fifth option that I
gave you okay but it's better than
you're just standing here his weight
actually went back and then you're like
having to get back here to try to do
that same
okay
um but the next best option and we I
have to use this all the time in here uh
because the beginner
UK gets scared as they get moved from
their Center and they will not spinally
displaced because they know uh that was
the Marshall opening for the for example
the nag waza and they start to resist
the nag waza from the get-go okay um so
the best option so he's he's going to
stay there okay is I will now Vector off
the front foot my ground Vector off the
front foot so normally you ground Vector
off the back foot cuz he's pushing and
you you need that back foot to to uh
make the connection but this time I'll
Vector off the front foot okay if I stay
on the back foot or neutral you see how
it's kind of dead but as I Vector off
the front foot and then then you have
him okay and you're Now using that
adhesion so you might have to change
some things as I come around this one
came that way and then you have the same
e
technique I don't know if that's the
best view camera so move wherever you
want so I'm Vector off the front foot
okay and you can combine the two so boom
I kind of got a little bit and then as
supposed to be entering over there for
the EO I use that foot to turn him into
that movement with that adhesion so
let's say he does not close his hand
okay and I do that same thing you see
w't
if you're doing for
example like um uh any of the of the arm
passes
okay same thing so boom connection move
move and you just will bring him with
your adhesions into the spinal
displacement okay that he's moving
forward now so you could do tyel henle
for example and we know in ours he's
pushing and hence that's why I turn
because that's what makes sense when
someone pushes turn it does not make
sense to enter on someone who's pulling
or not pushing okay you don't you don't
uh turn on that I'm sorry you don't turn
on that you enter on that okay so uh
here he is and there's no push and
you're trying to do this kind of stuff
you're going to eventually lose him okay
but here you C you connect
him that's all I'm doing so boom connect
I connect and then I can't move him
abruptly you'll lose him it's just
gradual movement gradual movement and
you move to where
you and that doesn't change if you
change hands so I changed hands on the
other side so let's do
that here we go so is just standing
there okay ground Vector here we go I
move it and then I move
it that would be what I would try to do
okay I hope that helps